Rap Battle verses I don't know I guess
this is just you have to put the words
in the sentence but
uh uh Snipes Rap Battle verses
I'm sorry this is the worst freestyle
well it's not even that but in a way
it's the illest and you know what I've
decided this is the greatest freestyle
I've ever heard in my life and let me
tell you why this guy knew he came with
nothing
and didn't give a [__] and still did it
that's my hero do you understand this
guy wanted to get by with pure him
that's the best
I'm going to
Neil McQueen that's him Neil Mickey
D O'Neal Mickey D shared this on my
Discord thanks Neil Mickey D
change it here it is I'm sorry little
kids but I'm a killer clown today
ah so from New Jersey
I'm a killer clown today
sorry little kids but I'm a clip I'm a
killer clown today
so [__]
Essex New Jersey
little kids but I'm a killer clown today
oh man that guy's my cousin say bullets
are gonna spray I'm from Brooklyn so
[__] absolutely was it lackadaisical
is that the word lackadaisical so
[__] lackadaisical dude sorry I'm a
bullet's gonna spray an accountant dude
I'm sorry little kid wow the fact that
the guy had so much faith in him before
he went that he goes get it
no
rhyming in a circle
I'm sorry little kid little kid but I'm
gonna kill a clown today I could say
bullets are gonna spray I'm from
Brooklyn that's all right but let me
just say I like to get close and
personal with a razor sharp object oh
it's British but let me just say this so
far
saying a lot of stuff and prefacing it
with let me just say
love that
I'm sorry little kids but I'm a killer
clown today I could say bullets are
gonna spray I'm from Brooklyn that's all
right oh he's from Brooklyn I like to
get close and personal so confusing
already so confusing already
bullets are gonna spray I'm from
Brooklyn that's okay let me just say I'm
British too drop object
but let me just say this okay I'm not
gonna stab you in the heart oh thank you
what I'm gonna do is grab a pen stab you
in the neck punch your lungs okay then
slam a blunt object into your stomach
[__] completely [__] off the rails
already and it is [__] 26 seconds in
unfucking believable this guy got to a
point in his rap battle career that he
thought he could enter this Cipher
and fail so miserably
26 26 seconds dude I could rap for 26
seconds
better than this
and I'm and I'll do it afterwards okay
an object into your stomach
so [__] specific a doctor dude and
cause internal bleeding
now before you die let me just say this
okay okay so he's very graphic he hit it
he stabbed you in the neck of the pen
and bludgeoned something else in his
stomach and then uh did it something
else right I can't remember what it was
but he did a lot of a lot of bad stuff
at causing internal bleeding now before
you die let me just say this so this is
going to be a banger this is gonna be
the punch line right this is where
everyone's gonna go oh oh
myself synopsis because I take my time
okay here we go
the reason I call myself snobs is
because I take my time to rhyme I'm not
complicated but well we know
the reason I call myself Snipes is
because I take my time to write I'm not
complicated imagine a guy telling you
that before you die
oh what
keep [__] stabbing the neck
bludgeoning you in the [__] internal
bleeding you're dying doing it coughing
up blood and he's like I just want you
to know the reason why they call me
Snipes is because I don't I take my time
to write I'm not complicated
I'm like a sniper I am straight for the
heart or the head I'm straight and
direct I might hide 2ks that way you'll
know when I hit you oh wow as soon as
you hit the ground the dog
crying dude
the dog is even like where's this
[__] get the ball no when I hit
you as soon as you hit the ground but
this guy said some [__] on Facebook here
we go to The Dark Knight [__] so don't
let me go all James Holmes on you Dark
Knight shooter is that a little bit too
soon
it's too soon to be rapping in a cipher
um say this as well if you want to be
the Joker why don't I give you a bottle
of pills a Chelsea smile
and instead of Heath Ledger dying why
don't you replace his death oh wow
that is the [__] hardest that is the
hardest rap bar I've ever heard in LA in
my life dude
oh you want to be the joker well how
about this instead of Heath Ledger dying
why don't you take his death
oh that's so hard dude this guy's [__]
this guy has bars dude
instead of Heath Ledger dying why don't
you replace his death
as well if you want to be the Joker why
don't I give you a bottle of pills a
Chelsea smile
and instead of Heath Ledger dying why
don't you replace his death
that's so hard I gave you a [__]
runner dude that is so hard I gave you a
runner I mean that's the hardest rap
lyric I ever [__] heard in my life
all right here we go moving on everybody
give two shits about a guy who looks
like a [__] meth head wow that's so
raw
you said in your first battle against
just talking just talking
his face looks like he got into a fight
just talking and reciting
[__] looks like you got into a fight
with the blunt side of an ax okay she
says face so many times
pausing for so long
still pausing they cut they literally
cut I think that I'm a soft car really I
couldn't give two [__] because you
don't know me you don't know what I've
lived so defensive Ricky Gervais in the
office yeah this is rap battling I can
give to Fox our lady for the factor of I
do this because I love it whether or not
I try I love what dude you're talking
you love what oh is the [__]
Postmates here
oh yeah
dude that is so [__] funny
it doesn't matter he rhymed once uh once
he rhymed once so far I think but at one
ounce
who basically that [__] just breaks like
Indian curry the after effects so
offensive and so offensive
go do something else go do something
with your life we should make a law
a kid ever have a kid get his dick in a
[__] we should shoot the little kid show
Chris and so violent dude he's coming
around dick in a con and make a kid
shoot the little kid so the most awful
thing I've ever heard in my life like
headless [__] chickens a waste of
space wow yeah but oh so guys some guy
goes damn
he was feeling it that guy I want to
know I want to interview that guy
space
[__] damn imma say this yeah maybe next
time I'll come rep prepared I got [__]
up last night I forgot my lines gonna
memorize them don't know where the [__]
I put the piece of paper in my house
admitting it
next time I'm not gonna [__] up I'm
gonna memorize my lines and I just
forgot the piece of paper I forgot to
bring the piece of paper from Brooklyn
just be wandering around having a ciggy
and then I'm just gonna find him and be
like oh [__] no there they are just
talking
that guy's my favorite rapper of all
time
great congratulations thank you very
much you have duh you are dubbed
congratulations greatest rapper of all
time